yeah hello and welcome to this video
then we're just a little bit in winter
do a quick bullet video yeah this looks
screwed up this is better man okay let's
join I couldn't find on a rapid game
that I wanted to originally play so
let's see it's just I'm just joining a
bit too late
just like 108 one or two games oops is a
little bit weird hope that loops the
device alright I had control with my USB
ports okay I think it should we are fine
so I have a pawn here just an extra pawn
for large and giving me material and
slice I like a bishop pair especially
okay on the guy doesn't have a bishop at
all oh no that was a bit stupid stupid
free move and okay strong not a big deal
yep and it's a mate I'm a bit behind you
behind it's something to that I can
manage so it's the window a recording
area looks fine give me a game please
here we go maybe not
ooh somebody knows knows theory funny
transposition here now talk to a Carol
Carol calm and that's okay 95 was
hanging with it's not such a big deal
okay not super happy about this position
but it's it's bearable I guess maybe
this it's not a good ending really not
oh no I didn't look at a six it's not
good and Queen B eight one blundering or
everything in oh my god okay
there was a very stupid game how can I
resign like this no very stupid okay
boom
[Music]
I must appoint me I can make it 100
94 on depression ignite a force what
White has to do and you play that seems
to know some Clary here
no I windy for I shouldn't take this
thing on a form okay doesn't really
doesn't really come into play this
question still not super easy but I
think you just trade everything down and
now 96 will probably win the pawn ok
pins up its trading so we're looking at
porn ending ok so I managed to get this
beserk in while I'm stepping behind them
that's a lot okay yeah I don't know
these openings are maybe not the best
them in a bullet scenario I mean I often
I would play the other guy but it takes
many moves did you do so let oh but I
didn't see arrow
and okay maybe isn't so bad and it's
maybe not so bad
Bishop 106 is extremely annoying
threatening before now we should be
seven I could have done maybe the night
b3 was possible but now I can do it Oh
gives me a fool
okay so I'm India India in the hunter
somewhat let's win some games and
everything is possible
I've gotten four games in but well it's
a high rated clear nice playing really
quickly
although my position is very okay but
he's very quickly very could complain I
could have chicken f2 it was a bit
stupid five years a hard time to cover
it so now come on we're good it's a good
position and I spend a bit of time down
and saw lots of pressure on white
position is very nice
but yeah okay so I won this and
Pawlenty's Ithaca was quite high rated
three points behind so not that much
that seems possible
[Music]
he's playing on really quickly
now but often the quality does suffer I
am if people play that cutting here my
position at least is completely winning
me it's maybe not the best but it is not
bad
giving me all those all this material
here take six look up right sometimes
lose track and got 20 seconds so it
should be easy okay so third place I had
this one really crappy game that I lost
the dress was kind of okay so
Nostradamus I kiss I saw the name me on
7th place okay about and it was too
quick and then let that self axiom that
position definitely sucks with Queen e2
was also somewhat strange to serum not
sure if 94 is actually good and and
let's just go back ie 5 is bad you
should see 5 he had maybe night a phone
let's just develop
the tech is info on that looks promising
lots of pins what is he doing
point things 90s that cannot be too bad
right age five I guess super good and
drinks the Queen
give me the Queen Gooden but it's okay
for a problem in itself okay so one that
one and in the lead in the lead I need a
game quickly at some time silly whom why
don't they get a game there are lots of
he answered one I've had quite well dr.
King's Indian attack it is quite easy to
play I've played then the kings in here
attack a really a lot in my junior days
and it was quite quite a good scoring
opening yeah he saw that I had a threat
down rook d7 good one I mean good that
is spotted it when I was trying the same
preparing f4 here hello that looks a bit
ugly
I like this pollution what looks like
like is in some trouble
I'll take it back and it is a really
really passive position for like okay
jump in and after the cakes cakes I'm
controlling the D file forever this is
good yeah that's true actually I did not
really look at the clock all and much I
now see that I'm a bit behind and I did
not see this okay it's still pretty good
for white blue my bishop is bad it's
really a bad piece I don't see how I
activate it okay what he now has given
me a four piece okay I won it on time it
was still tough and it took a long time
so Michael is leading again let's go on
come on quickly quick preview from a
knight f6 I can do
hmm come on what's going on here
okay so I got the winner because why did
not move mokou is still leading amazing
squad tremendously well we'd like to
play mm maybe is that the guy that I
lost is that yes the game Macomb
the guy that I lost against I don't
quite remember now I will have some
chances yonder on the kingside it's got
very very few squares left okay and this
one no H fool well how do you save the
queen' here a lot save the queen neither
the swiss lost right so he has to do
something funky like neither form which
is CERN in fact still quite a mess 94 93
it looks a bit messy
I mean white is winning but you still
have to do it and I think I'm wait
93 place
okay so how was I think reasonably clean
maybe there were some things that I miss
but it looked it looked okay so I took
the lead with seven minutes to go
King berserk guys from Amata looking to
the strange old renew but okay why not
doesn't look too bad let's close it down
yeah it's really closed maybe it'd be
too much m and it's really a good idea
now doesn't look good
wow what the heck he's playing this
really well and then I'm not playing it
no plane it would game here which is a
good job I think no no I didn't take it
was a mouse clip of course swung through
somehow somehow on
I hope g2 that's a bit of a problem very
lucky very lucky win but you need that
lucky win totally killed me down now
that super close position oh that's
actually really bad
hello game so Marco Wham he still here
on my trail demijohn it's going all six
free move look at that really high every
single time and I don't think that this
is good for white position game sell
into into all kinds of discovered
attacks so I'm here g6 maybe is that
good I don't know g6 threatening Bishop
g5 it's pretty pretty awkward it still
cannot go h5 because of the check just
develop everything I mean this King is
definitely more in trouble deadline okay
so maybe for Queen b6 yeah you do still
have the Queen trapped
and that's it okay three left and I'm
four points ahead which is good maybe
not enough I don't know if I lose
something I'm gonna do some stupid game
he can definitely catch me oh I'm
killing him this is one of them guys
swung right behind in the standings so
we place King pinion and playing the
fake arrow if all objects affords a nice
nice little tactic difficult but still
okay and I'm like no looks a little bit
shaky which looks shaky c5 oh yeah and
just a snap okay well here this is at
least not losing in fact in fact I might
be still a tad more comfortable him it
just trades everything in I can go here
though it might still be interesting
okay tickets Queen f4
just really net anything you skip this
yeah it was equal well it's not equal I
just know what I said of my time is is a
problem in fact it's a huge problem
position is now really okay I cannot do
it I'm done I am okay nice one he was uh
and I'm actually why what what how what
how did that happen how did he get to 44
I was four points ahead and now I'm five
points behind what what kind of thing is
that okay and what what happened here
he did what sorry guys I don't get it he
got four point one two in this in the in
the in the process yeah Wow yeah not
much that you can do about that I mean I
was a pretty city loss but but yeah -
good strange I don't know - really
really quick wins at the end that he got
that okay but I think it was a wonderful
event and I had chances to win it but
losing at the end here was pretty dumb
especially yeah yeah it was a pretty
okay position and but I did not I don't
don't know when you have spent the time
right on the opening probably err okay
anyway I hope you enjoyed it funny
little bully video thanks for watching
guys guys bye-bye